Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here.
After the release of the spectacular Avengers
Infinity War trailer, we've finally got a
much better look at what the Avengers will
be facing up to when Thanos and his Black
Order invade the Earth.
And now some amazing descriptions from Infinity
War Lego sets have leaked that may reveal
what we can expect from six key action scenes
in the movie.
My superhero giveaway is also running on this
video for all my subscribers and I'll have
full details on that later in the video.
And just before I go any further, obviously
I'm talking potential spoilers and speculation
for the upcoming Avengers: Infinity War movie,
plus previous Marvel films.
So, if you prefer, you can tap in the top
right to watch my breakdown of the official
trailer instead.
Let's get into the details of these six key
scenes which come from the release of Lego
set descriptions published on a toy site called
Exoforce.
I'm going to start with a particularly interesting
set called "The Search For Thor's Weapon"
which includes minifigures for Thor, Rocket
Racoon and Groot and which also mentions an
unknown infinity stone.
The set describes a quest where Thor goes
off with Rocket and Groot in search of a new
weapon, now that he no longer has Mjolnir.
Curiously, this description fits in with a
piece of official concept art that Marvel
released in a very early Infinity War teaser
video of Thor wielding what looks like an
axe and Rocket firing alongside him.
The Lego set description also states that
Thor travels to a red planet called Nidavellir,
one of the Nine Realms.
This planet which is inhabited by dwarves
is actually where Mjolnir was originally forged,
in the words of Odin, 'in the heart of a dying
star'.
The leaked description mentions that Thor
using "space forges", which I think explains
this mysterious shot of Thor in the trailer
where he's straining to operate or control
some kind of machine.
An unspecified Infinity Stone is also mentioned
in the description, as well as using energy
to create a new axe.
The axe referred to here is most likely Jarnbjorn,
a weapon forged by dwarves and used by Thor
before Mjolnir.
The axe is incredibly sharp with the power
to slice through almost anything, and it's
also virtually indestructible.
Based on the description, it also sounds like
an Infinity Stone might be involved in the
creation of Thor's new weapon and I think
this could be the Reality Stone, which we
last saw given to the Collector at the end
of Thor: The Dark World.
We know from the Infinity War trailer that
Thanos already has the Power Stone and the
Space Stone; that his Black Order is extracting
the Mind Stone from Vision; and that Doctor
Strange has the Time Stone.
And at the moment, I feel that the Soul Stone
is probably going to be in Wakanda.
That leaves the Reality Stone, which was actually
mentioned in some recently leaked Infinity
War footage where Thanos interrogates the
Collector about an Infinity Stone, which Taneleer
Tivan claims he sold to someone.
If what the Collector says is true, then I
wonder whether the person he sold it to might
be Peter Dinklage's character who then takes
it to the Dwarven home Nidavellir.
The next set is based back on Earth with minifigures
of Bruce Banner, Falcon and Proxima Midnight,
plus the Soul Stone.
It describes a scene where Proxima Midnight
has captured a tower and starts firing on
a Hulkbuster Bruce Banner.
This seems to confirm my theory from my trailer
breakdown video that it's not actually Tony
Stark we see in the Hulkbuster armour in the
Infinity War trailer.
A six-limbed enemy is also mentioned in the
description, which means that the four-armed,
two-legged Outriders that the Black Order
commands will also be involved in this scene.
Finally, the set description orders Falcon
to dive down and capture the Soul Stone, which
seems to confirm the final stone is being
kept in Wakanda, given that's where the trailer
shows the Hulkbuster.
The epic battle in Wakanda, which we saw teased
in the trailer, also features in another set
that includes Captain America, Black Widow,
and an army of Outriders, as well as the Space
Stone.
The set description talks about Captain America
and Black Widow helping in the defence of
Wakanda against the invading Outriders.
Interestingly, it mentions that Cap uses his
shield in the battle, which confirms we will
be seeing Cap back with some kind of shield,
as we also heard Black Panther say in the
trailer.
We know that Thanos will be after the Time
Stone, which at the end of Doctor Strange
was being stored in Strange's Sanctum Santorum.
This Lego set description suggests that we'll
see Spider-Man and Iron Man join with Doctor
Strange to fend off two of Thanos's Black
Order, Cull Obsidian and Ebony Maw, during
their attack on the New York Sanctum.
The fifth set reveals a potentially intriguing
moment involving Black Order member Corvus
Glaive, Vision, Black Panther and Shuri.
It describes a scene where Corvus Glaive is
launching an attack and Black Panther then
enters the battle while Shuri attempts to
remove the Mind Stone from Vision.
Now, this seems somewhat at odds with the
scene of Corvus Glaive attacking Vision's
Mind Stone with the tip of his blade in the
trailer.
So, this could be a moment before then where
Shuri is trying to remove the Infinity Stone
before Corvus Glaive gets hold of it.
Alternatively, it might be that Shuri is trying
to remove it because Vision has fallen under
the control of the Black Order when Corvus
Glaive touched his Mind Stone in this moment
in the trailer.
And the final Lego set describes what it calls
"Thanos: The Last Battle" and has Iron Man,
Star-Lord and Gamora going up against the
Mad Titan.
The scene appears to take place in space with
Thanos using a huge sword to defend himself.
The sword Thanos uses sounds like it might
be a little nod to the Infinity Sword which
appeared on the animated Super Hero Squad
Show or possibly Surtur's Twilight Sword which
we already saw in Thor: Ragnarok.
OK, so those are the six leaked Lego set and
scene descriptions, but before we assume that
these are 100% guaranteed to happen in the
movie, we need to bear in mind that these
are toy sets which may be playing fast and
loose with aspects of the story in the film.
Toy sets have sometimes switched characters
around.
For example, for Avengers: Age of Ultron,
a toy was released of Captain America on the
motorbike that gets launched from the Avengers
quinjet; whereas in the movie, it was Black
Widow who was on that motorbike.
Even if they aren't all accurate, though,
some of these Lego set descriptions do seem
to match up with the snippets we've seen in
the first Infinity War trailer, and give us
a bit of a better understanding of what might
be going on.
So, what do you think about these potential
action scenes for Avengers: Infinity War?
And what are you most looking forward to seeing
in the movie?
Let me know your thoughts and theories in
the comments below.
Also be sure to subscribe and comment to enter
my Avengers: Infinity War giveaway for a chance
to win a very cool Marvel Funko Pop!
And if you liked this, do hit that thumbs
up button, and tap the screen for more of
my Marvel theories and Infinity War videos.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!